us writer director Jordan peels
much-anticipated follow-up to his horror
masterpiece get out is finally here and
it was worth the wait what starts as an
apparently simple home invasion Fright
Fest quickly evolves into something
bigger as Pele spins bigger and thicker
ideas into a movie with bigger and
bigger implications the result is a
conceptually weighty horror film that
keeps you guessing and thinking right up
to the very last minute and that means
we've got plenty to talk about with that
in mind here are the best and worst
things about us oh and it should go
without saying but there are spoilers
ahead for the entire movie you've been
warned horror cinema has a huge capacity
for pushing actors to their emotional
and physical limits and the genres long
tradition of placing vulnerable women at
the center of stories means we've gotten
truly legendary performances out of some
major talents from Jamie Lee Curtis to
Sigourney Weaver to Toni Collette
Adelaide played by Oscar winner Lupita
Nyong'o is the center of us and she
rises to the occasion by adding another
legendary performance to horror film
history a performance made all the more
powerful by her dual roles as Adelaide
she is vulnerable but strong scared but
determined loving with savage as red
Adelaide's tethered double she is both
an entirely different personality and
every bit Adelaide's mirror image
she jerks in twists when Adelaide is
graceful grins when Adelaide gasps in
terror and croaks for Adelaide speaks
it's a magnificent pair of performances
and while there are certainly plenty of
other things to recommend about us her
daring and brilliant performance is the
first thing many moviegoers will come
away talking about the Tyler family who
joined the Wilsons for a day at the
beach in the first act of the film are
presented as shallow bickering people
with no real sense of love between them
while that creates plenty of
opportunities for comedy it does mean
the blow is dulled a little bit when
their murders happen midway through the
movie yes that sequence is funny and
gets quite tense when the Wilsons show
up but you get the sense that the
Tyler's didn't really need to be as
broad as they are particularly when the
film already roots us in the emotional
reality of the Wilsons before he was an
acclaimed genius of horror Jordan Peele
was an acclaimed genius of comedy thanks
to his collaborate
with keegan-michael key which resulted
in the TV series key and Peele and the
film Keanu Peele never made some kind of
hard cut from one genre to the other
though as a horror fan he has an innate
understanding of the role comedy plays
in scary movies something he
demonstrated over and over again with
his debut horror feature get out how do
you find me I'm TS mother we handle us
is another masterclass in balancing
laughs and scares beginning with the
answer play of the Wilson family as they
travel together in the car and
continuing throughout the entire film
don't do drugs like his horror deals
comedy start small with little dad jokes
from Gabe and comforting family banter
it continues to build from there until
its intertwining with the scares it's
Gabe wrestles with his tethered double
on his new boat ultimately in the most
desperate situations in the film the
comedy provides a welcome sense of fun
as the Wilson family can't help
commenting on how bizarre their
situation is even as they're trying to
survive it all of that plus a welcomed
needle drop from NWA means that us is
often as hilarious as it is terrifying
us begins with a relatively tight
concept evil duplicates are invading and
trying to kill us
as the film expands and expands it keeps
expanding until it essentially has
nationwide implications and the themes
just keep expanding with it because of
that expansion us gets messy and not
just in terms of the body count the film
swells until it becomes not just about
our own dark sides but about how some
people prosper while others suffer in an
unfair system and how the powerful
manipulate regular people in unseen ways
and about the empty gestures of charity
and hope that are mostly about public
relations and about the links we'll go
to in order to take what we feel we
deserve and so on and so on these are
all valid themes but by the end the film
tries to throw all these things at us at
once and some of them land hard while
others simply fall by the wayside it's a
shotgun approach to the symbolism at the
heart of the movie and it doesn't work
as well as it should over
it could even be said that without get
out to compare it to we wouldn't notice
the difference but it's there and it's
noticeable still you got to get the
movie credit even if it's reject seeds
its grasp at least it tried to reach at
all with us Jordan Peele created some
legendary creepy nightmare is called the
tavern and they live up to all the
promise they had in the films trailers
stick with me stain the design of the
tethered is deceptively simple and even
though we don't learn why they look the
way they do red jumpsuits gloves sandals
and scissors until late in the film
their look works from the very beginning
when we see them standing in the Wilson
family's driveway silent and stoic as
the concept that the movies heart
continues expanding and its pathology
gets more complex the tethered
themselves remain deceptively simple
movie monsters their behavior can change
a bit and the motives can become more
clear but the deliberate almost robotic
way in which they pursue their goals
does not and that makes them terrifying
they're extremely effective movie
monsters thanks in part to peels less is
more approach and the actors inhabiting
them make them unforgettable slasher
villains as the film's final act leads
Adelaide down into a series of tunnels
we finally learn what the tethered
really are genetic copies of people
living on the surface one human and body
but vacant in spirit who were created to
serve his underground puppets for the
powerful to manipulate the citizenry it
eventually all went wrong and the
tethered were simply left in the tunnels
to fend for themselves until read
herself began to organize the uprising
we see in the film it's an intriguing
explanation for a lot of seemingly
unrelated things but the way it's
finally revealed to us with read
explaining it all via voiceover could
have been better we've seen this villain
do all manner of frightening
unpredictable and compelling things and
now in this moment she's reduced to
monologuing in the dark room because the
film has to dish out a whole bunch of
information in a very short time it's
perhaps the one in elegant thing the
film has to offer and it still manages
to be interesting even if it's clunky
peel is such a talented writer skilled
at wielding high concepts in new ways
mixing comedy and drama and pacing in a
way that makes it look easy that he
could shoot his films in a style that's
merely competent and still come away
with hits as long as everything's in
focus and the editing isn't confusing
the stew
we will still work and the characters
will still come through peel isn't
content to just keep things adequate
though and that shows through and the
visual flourishes present throughout us
every frame of this film looks amazing
it doesn't matter if you're a fan of
horror or not this is some of the finest
visual storytelling you're likely to see
in any movie in 2019 the eventual
explanation for who and what the
tethered really are and why they were
created as an intriguing one and helps
to set up that amazing final shot of
bloody hands across America but things
start to fall apart the more you think
about the logistics of it all why was
the entrance to the tethered underground
tunnels unlocked why didn't more wander
to the surface world more often why can
the tethered act with free will in some
scenes and become mirror images of their
counterparts the next there are probably
great explanations for these questions
but the film is too interested in moving
relentlessly forward to give them to us
and that might take a little air out of
the story's tires if you get stuck
thinking too much about it all on that
same subject it's confirmed in the
movies final moments that Adelaide is
actually the original tethered and read
was the original Adelaide who she
strangled and locked up in the tunnels
after that first carnival encounter all
those years ago the twist works because
it's the kind of thing that just burrows
into your brain as the credits are
rolling but it also feels like the last
brick that almost makes the tower
beneath it start to topple if there's
one impulse the movie maybe should have
resisted it might be this one unless we
get to explore the true implications of
this revelation and the inevitable
sequel us to a bus full of us now that
sounds scary check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]